Republicans could bring a tax reform
plan to the Senate floor today after it
cleared a key committee at least nine
GOP senators have expressed concern
about the bill Republicans can only
afford to lose two votes their concerns
include repealing Obamacare as
individual mandate taxes on small
businesses and property tax deductions
for Republican senators say they're
worried about adding to the country's 20
trillion dollar debt one of them is
Oklahoma's James Lankford he joins us
now from Capitol Hill
senator good morning good morning to you
let me ask you about one of your chief
concerns every estimate that I've seen
shows that the Senate tax care plan
would add to the debt about half a
trillion dollars in debt even if you
have modest economic growth will you
vote for a plan that adds to the debt so
what I've done is over the last couple
of days is to be able to work with
leadership and with the committee's to
be able to say how can we create a
backstop behind us the estimates that we
have and again again there are lots of
economic estimates out there some saying
above some saying below the the number
that's needed what I have done is asked
for a backstop to be in place to say in
case the economic numbers not reached
there will be a way to be able to
recover some of those revenues so yes I
am on board with this bill because I
want to see the good economic growth
that's coming with it but I also want to
make sure that we're protecting future
taxpayers as well and debt and deficit I
hear what you're saying that backstop or
some people are calling it a trigger
that in other words if that economic
growth doesn't come it would trigger
higher taxes but the US Chamber of
Commerce is asking how would a trigger
operate once a recession hits correct so
what we're writing into the language is
their protection from recession there's
- well there's really two aspects that
are let me say this we're writing in a
protection of recession so if there is a
recession the trigger turns off but the
second part of that is if we do this
large tax cut and we broaden the base of
what's happening economically we better
not have a recession at that point this
should actually charge up the economy so
I think some of the concerns about a
pending recession right after you're
doing tax cuts are unfounded but we are
building language and to make sure that
we're protecting it either way because
obviously I don't want to have that
either
you'd want to have a situation where
you're in a recession in taxes go up and
we're not talking about a large tax
increase and we're talking about small
things around the edges to be able to
guard against if you
lost increases in deficits so that both
of those can be done well so senator let
me ask you a question about the
middle-class folks people making under
seventy five thousand dollars a year
would see a TAC heist attack tight in
2027
if these tax cuts aren't renewed
meanwhile the corporate tax cut is
permanent so why not make the tax cuts
for middle class individuals permanent
as well because of Washington scoring
that's why and that's been the
frustration all along that we have with
the Senate is the scoring requirements
running the bills that we do the way you
have to set it up it has to meet certain
standards in certain time periods we can
make all the business aspects permanent
which is very important to us you've got
to have some sort of consistency for
business to be able to plan for the
future for capital investment the
individual rates are not permanent but
that is exactly like what was done in
2001 and then never renewed in 2011 and
made permanent
I would assume we would have something
very similar to that with this one that
ten years out we would also renew those
and be able to keep going on it you need
to be able to protect rates you need to
be able to protect the economic growth
the way you do that is from the business
side in the advanced planning center can
you help us understand every time we
talk to politicians about the tax plan
we get a lot of numbers I feel like my
head's gonna pop out because you hear
all of these conflicting and
contradicting information can you just
very simply explain why this is good for
the middle class and that it doesn't
benefit the wealthy in America just in
one or two sentences would be great well
I tell the people back home the most
confusing thing about Washington is
trying to get the accurate number the
best thing that we can do in this
situation is allow businesses to be able
to have more of their own money to hire
more people to buy more equipment to
invest in new ways and to be able allow
people in the middle class especially to
have more money for savings and for
spending that increases economic
activity around the country more
economic activity more people have a job
more people are paid more at their jobs
there's more income that happens back
and forth and buying and selling some
more products are made that makes the
economy healthier the economy has been
stuck for 10 years at 2% growth
historically America has grown at 3%
we've got to get us back up to a normal
healthy economy again this is a way to
bump the economy to be able to get it
growing and healthy again senator I want
to ask you about what any other big
headlines today and that is North Korea
and I know you are in the Senate
Intelligence Committee
what we saw yesterday was that the North
Koreans have made some huge
technological advances including the
fact that they could this missile could
reach Washington DC also that they can
fuel this thing very quickly before
perhaps we could launch a preemptive
strike how much does that concern you it
should concern everyone the United
States and the entire world community
the UN Security Council is meeting today
to talk about it China released side a
statement that was dead set against it
Russia really sought a statement saying
this is a provocative act from North
Korea the entire world is reaching into
North Korea and saying stop slow down
you are intentionally trying to provoke
a conflict in the days ahead by doing
these if that warhead that was that
excuse me that missile that was launched
yesterday had a warhead on it are you
convinced that our intelligence would
have been good enough to take it out
preemptively well the first thing
wouldn't necessarily be intelligence the
first thing would be quick response we
have four different that missile high
altitude systems in South Korea to be
able to shoot down a high altitude
missiles we have missile interception
systems in multiple other locations
around the Pacific Rim as well to be
able to attack it once it goes up that
missile was up in the air for 53 minutes
so Rapid Response you you have a couple
of minutes to be able to think through
plan strategize what you're gonna do and
they be able to launch countermeasures
on it
so a 53 minute missile launch is very
significant a lot of distance but you do
have time to respond
senator Lankford thank you so much for
joining us thank you